before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round dog truth or dare
we have uh sylvia hooper hi sylvia
okay it's all about your leopard belt
look at this
i was noticing the nails
hey all right what's it going to be a
druther or a dare ruth okay hit us
so in honor of international women's day
going to talk about our biggest female
inspiration and so for me mine is my mom
gwendolyn hooper she was a foster parent
fostered many children and adopted my
brother and i and instilled in us the
values of education hard work and
determination and so want to know who
your biggest inspiration is oh
i think i know who ross might pick yeah
i'm with you i'm a mama's boy all the
way and my mom
was just
so filled with that sort of goodness and
that heart that it sounds like your mom
has as well and there's something that
just there's there's no love like like
the love from a good mama right yeah
yeah thank you
thank you for asking what about you
[Applause]
my girls
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you sylvia
thank you both thank you so much and we
celebrate your mom today and we always
celebrate your mom rossi here at the
show thank you he has a permanent
fixture in our heart oh gosh so
thank you thank you thank you
thank you everybody
[Music]
you